Remember how I told you that your editor
is like that steak knife that was
built to fulfill a specific purpose?
Well, that wasn't the entire truth.
It's true that most editors have figured
out how to do a great job with basic
editing, but almost all modern editors
can be extended with functionality.
In Sublime's case,
all of it comes from a healthy
community of developers, like you.
They were missing something and
built it.
And indeed, right now your
Sublime is a genetic text editor.
It doesn't care about you
being a web developer.
In the next step you customize
it with the help of James, so
it becomes a front-end
development editor.
>> Sublime doesn't have a built
in plug in repository, so
the first thing we'll need to
do is install package control.
Its the only time we'll manually
need to install a plugin.
We'll take this scary looking
block of text from the notes and
paste it into Sublime's terminal.
And with that it's fetching the plug in
and installing all of the dependencies.
Let's test whether it worked.
Type Command+Shift+P to bring
up Sublime's command palette.
This drop down menu is
useful in many ways.
Because it contains all
the actions Sublime can do.
I generally use it to discover
stuff I didn't know about,
like this toggle comment action and
to execute actions that don't have
shortcuts or have crazy long ones.
But right now, type in P-A-C,
and you'll see many new commands
associated with package control.
The one we really care
about is install package.
This one right here.
This is the list of all of
the packages in the repository.
So now that we're prepared, let's
install a few of our favorite plugins.
This list of plugins is also in the
notes for you to quickly copy and paste.
Through package controls and
stall command, please install Emmet,
Sidebar Enhancements,
Color Picker and Color Highlighter.
Some plugins require
restarting the editor.
So to make sure to do that after
you have installed everything.
Emmet dramatically extends and improves
Sublime's built in text snippets.
Its craziest feature is the ability
to use CSS selectors to create new
HTML markup.
I know that sounds a bit confusing,
but let me tell you what I mean.
Let's say I need a list with four
items in my index.html file.
I can do that by typing
the CS selector shown here.
Then pressing Tab expands the selector
into the HTML we specify.
Emmet comes with a lot
more built in magic
that you should definitely check out
in the link in the instructor's notes.
The Sidebar Enhancements plugin has
a pretty descriptive and spot on name.
It mostly extends the right-click
menu of Sublime's
usually pretty bare-bones sidebar with
all of the stuff you would expect.
Deleting files, new folders and so on.
But also, some nifty stuff such
as copying content as a data URI.
Now, these last two,
Color Picker and Color Highlighter
work together to make editing and
working with colors in CSS, much easier.
Pressing Cmd+Shift+C opens
the system color picker and
allows you to quickly choose a color.
And when the cursor is placed in or
around an existing color,
picking a new one will update it.
The highlighter outlines or
underlines colors it finds in your
CSS with a preview so you always
have an idea what you're looking at.